well we have the Jewish first verdict
and Reuters are reporting from inside
court that Donald Trump did not rape e
Gene Carroll that's the verdict that he
clearly wanted to hear that jury of six
men
but the jury has found that Donald Trump
did sexually abuse e Gene Carroll that
was a lesser of the sexually sexual
assault
charges
and the jury has awarded Eugene Cattle
two million dollars
in compensation for that battery claim
so to repeat the jury has decided that
Donald Trump did not rape egn Carroll
but they have decided that he did
sexually abuse her
consequently they have awarded Eugene
Carroll two million pounds in
compensation
that's three questions addressed by the
jury there are further questions to be
addressed
namely on defamation Donald Trump
accused eating Carol of lying about this
incident she's been suing him for
battery and defamation we will get to
the defamation verdicts very shortly
indeed why don't we just uh break down
James exactly just just to remind uh
remind viewers exactly what's uh crossed
in these last few moments so uh the
headline of course uh being that uh the
jury did not find uh that Donald Trump
raped e Gene Carroll but uh did uh find
that uh Trump sexually abused her uh and
they have awarded E.J Carroll at two
million dollars in compensatory damages
in terms of the defamation they have
awarded Carol twenty thousand dollars in
punitive damages uh and uh found that
Trump did defame Carol in an October
2022 truth social uh posts when he
called her a con job uh and uh has
awarded her 2.7 million in
compensationary Damages for uh
defamation and some more of these are
crossing as we speak as James was saying
there were a lot of individual uh
different uh verdicts to be announced
and they're also awarding her a further
280 000 in punitive damages for uh
defamation so we've seen a two million
award a 2.8 million award and a 280 000
uh dollar uh award and the headline
being that Donald Trump was not found to
have raped Eugene Carroll but was found
to have sexually abused her